il est 16h15 c'est la fin des classes au
cours charles péguy de sartrouville
c'est l'heure des services ranger la
cour faire la vaisselle nettoyer les
vitres les 79 élèves de l'école sont
répartis dans des équipes internes
niveaux chacune sa tâche pour l'équipe
de stacy c'est le nettoyage des tables
et des chaises de l'école qu'on fait un
service et baï faut être toujours
ensemble et non à droite ou à gauche
créée en 2016 cette école fait partie du
réseau espérance banlieue elle compte
sept classes du cp à la 5e marie pierre
collet est enseignante depuis 30 ans
arrivé dans le réseau il ya quatre ans
elle enseigne aujourd'hui à une classe
de cm2 en rep chalet 24 25 élèves c'est
comme si là je vous avais tout le temps
en demi groupe donc on ne peut se
permettre quand même beaucoup plus de
manipulations en sciences notamment et
dans d'ailleurs dans toutes les autres
matières en maths enfin voilà on
n'hésite pas à sortir du matériel pour
pour travailler concrètement cet
établissement destiné aux élèves
décrocheurs du primaire au collège c'est
la possibilité pour ces jeunes de
développer aussi un sentiment
d'appartenance des équipes aux noms de
personnalités historiques un uniforme
comme un tout c'est l'hymne national
entonné chaque lundi matin en levant le
drapeau national j'aime bien qu'il y ait
des uniformes et
j'aime bien aussi qu'on s'a semblent
tous les matins pour peu on ça semble le
lundi pour chanter l'hymne national on
travaille bien on reste quand même ça je
veux on pourra la voir alors l'uniforme
c'est un vêtement effectivement que les
enfants méritent lorsque j'arrive à
l'école ils sont civile entre guillemets
et de par leur attitude
en classe et à l'extérieur la classe ils
montrent qu'ils ont acquis et qui vous
mettent en pratique les cinq règles d'or
qui sont être joyeux penser aux autres
être propres et ordonnés être vrai et
bien travailler être curieux et ce soir
la cérémonie des avis a permis de
récompenser deux élèves nous avons pu
vous voir progresser de jour en jour
depuis le début que vous êtes ici est ce
que vous vous engagez par cette prise
donné forme à respecter les cinq règles
d'or est bien avec une grande joie je
vous le donne donc vous n'aurez plus
qu'à des coûts de votre vécu pour le
match
avant de conclure la journée sur le
traditionnel cri de guerre du cours
charles péguy de sartrouville